everyone has the right to choose what
they want to do and you know he had a
great career and he was a great player
so everybody wishes you know they could
be healthy all the time and and it's a
very another contact sport he's you know
certainly had his fair share injuries
Tom Brady speaking to WEEI earlier this
week about the surprised decision of
Andrew Luck to retire from the game at
the age of 29 and I just can't help but
think at some level it's almost like
Highlander right remember that movie
Chris yeah where another one's down and
Tom Brady gets stronger and he keeps
going and it fuels him to go even
farther to play even longer because it's
it's so rare and when guys are dropping
off before 30 and he's still going
before 40 I feel like he's gonna push it
to 45 and beyond maybe who knows he
pushes it to 50 he still looks like he's
in his twenties he still looks great
there's no doubt about that
I mean his arm is still as strong as
ever and it's you know it's a special
arm that way excuse me the big thing
with Tom Brady will never be his arm or
his decision-making or understanding how
to play the game it's gonna be is he
willing to stand there in the pocket and
not flinch and do some of that where it
affects the decisions or the throws we
saw some of that at points last year now
they overcame it and he overcame it
because he's freaking Tom Brady and he's
awesome
but there were moments and I remember
going on radio stations in Boston and TV
stations in Boston where they saw it too
I think it's been kind of a race from
everybody's memory because of the
playoff run and the Super Bowl and he
was phenomenal but there was question
marks there in late November and
December ooh you know it doesn't look
like the Tom Brady we saw yeah or no or
anything like that but it's still it's
absolutely amazing and I think it's even
more amazing that he kind of tinkered
with his motion the last few years to
really extend his career make him better
than now than he was in 2012 and 13
mike/chris remember that moment against
the Steelers but was like he saw a ghost
and he threw the ball and he was
supposedly throwing it away and it got
intercepted that's what I mean the prime
example
like like what do you really see there
and and it's always the legs to watch
uh-huh we've talked about this before
once he starts getting hit because he
can't move away from pressure the way
that he used to that's when he's going
to begin to wear down the arm will be
there but if he doesn't have the legs to
get away from pressure and he starts
throwing the ball prematurely because he
he senses that pressure when maybe he
shouldn't that's when he's no longer
gonna be Tom Brady but he's still his
hashtag Tommy yes he still is the
all-time all-time greatest in my book I
know you would say Aaron Rodgers I say
Tom Brady ok arguable I understand it
but without Andrew Locke right and and I
don't know how big of a rival Andrew
Luck ever was he had the potential to
become one and Chris Ballard had that
mic drop moment in early 2018 the
rivalry is back on they got together in
a playoff game a few years ago the day
before deflategate hit it did not go
well for the Indianapolis Colts but who
are Tom Brady's rivals right now in the
NFL he's got those three young
quarterbacks in the AFC East that that
are not ready to consider themselves Tom
Brady's rivals so who are they yeah I
mean it's a great question I don't know
if there's any one guy out there
especially that fits that role of being
like Peyton Manning we know that was his
number one rival now yeah Russell Wilson
Cam Newton
they have winning records against him
Russell Wilson of course lost the
biggest one at you you know he lost the
Super Bowl so that word this is regular
season stuff we're looking at here drew
Brees has done well but we only see that
matchup once every four years
Big Ben has certainly struggled hey we
could throw you live Manning on this
list too now Eli I think he's 1 & 2 in
the regular season but he's to a no in
the Super Bowl and then that means 3 & 2
against you know Tom Brady so I don't
know if there's one out there right now
it does look like mahomes and Brady
could be playing two more times again
this year I'll say that much into where
that could start to become something
maybe if Brady continues to play the
year after this and then again they
might play again two more times out here
to where we get one more little rivalry
with Brady but I don't know if anyone
truly stands out right now hey and let
me tell you I mean mahomes oh and two
against Brady but mahomes did everything
in his power to win those two games that
was Brady rising to a higher level with
the chips down he had the big throw to
Gronk in the regular-season game when it
was going back and forth and then he he
had the the drives that tied the game
and won the game in overtime in the AFC
Championship but you know if you're
looking for that that that true rival it
has to be somebody that you're likely to
encounter in the postseason
yes and it feels like mahomes is that
guy now yeah although even though my
Holmes has yet to beat him and it feels
like this is the year that the pendulum
may swing I think this and the more I
ponder this Chris the obsession from
coach Bill Belichick to win games on the
road because they went 3 and 5 last year
they don't want to go back to Kansas
City
sure playoff game this year because I
think Belichick knows deep down you're
not going to escape two years in a row
from that setting your only chance of
beating mahomes in the postseason is to
bring him to you and and they're there
conscious that even though Bill
Belichick never looks beyond today yeah
they're conscious of that and that's not
really planning they need that one seed
if they're gonna face my homes again in
January well he knows my homes is only
gonna get better so he's not he's not
going in the season going well he might
fall off he knows he's gonna get better
and the Kansas City defense can't get
any worse you know that's again - it's
always drives me crazy when we get into
the quarterback first quarterback
conversation I'm gonna go well you know
there's there's a lot of other guys on
the field there they're never on the
field together I know it's a rivalry and
they're never on the exact same it does
drive me crazy but I know the business
were in and I'm a football fan too so I
get it but yeah I mean you know Kansas
City's defense stunk I mean they've been
one of the worst in football they're
secondary they blew it up because it was
so bad and then there's you know the
Patriots who have a phenomenal team but
I'm with you the mahomes one and I don't
think that the Pittsburgh one could get
real I think the Steelers are the real
deal I will be shocked if they're not
standing there you know at least in the
playoffs when the season comes to an end
and you know I think their team has
built now better than ever
to match up with the Patriots since the
Patriots to have China kind of change
their style of play where we've talked
about you know more to back running sets
running the football that plays into the
Steelers hands more you know their issue
was when it was Wes Welker and Edelman
and Aaron Hernandez and Gronkowski and
everybody was spread out and they were
playing zone defense and Brady was just
boom boom boom picking them apart they
couldn't match up with that but he want
to play Smash Mouth pits
can match up with New England that way
that's where I think it's a little bit
more dangerous maybe than years past Cam
Newton the Panthers quarterback his to a
no lifetime against Tom Brady they've
yet to meet in the Super Bowl they could
have in Super Bowl 50 that was the game
where the Patriots had to go to Denver
and they couldn't get past the Broncos
otherwise it would have been Cam Newton
versus Tom Brady in Super Bowl 50
Russell Wilson 2 & 1 versus Tom Brady
the loss coming in Super Bowl xlix and
you could argue that if the play calling
had been a little more astute on the
sideline Russell Wilson would be
three-and-oh against Tom Brady and how
differently we would feel about those
Seahawks teams of several years back in
and we'd feel differently about Tom
Brady if he hadn't won that oh gosh I
mean then all of a sudden they would
have been three and three in Super Bowls
I mean we've been gun gam know England
hasn't won a Super Bowl in in 11 years
what's going on here you know there's
certainly the history would be a lot
different if they just gave the ball to
Marshawn Lynch up the middle the other
guy we got a mention who I think was up
there as far as other than Peyton
Manning for performing the best ok maybe
Eli - I gotta give you like credit to
Eli did win a game up in New England in
2011 and then of course won the Super
Bowl other than those two though Joe
Flacco was a pain in the butt for the
New England Patriots he was one of the
few quarterbacks in all of football it
was always I mean never fazed by oh I
got to go up there and play the Patriots
and deal with the Boston mystique and
all of that a wee dessert he deserves to
be in this conversation nonetheless I
agree with you completely 2 & 2 against
Tom Brady in the postseason and you know
if the if the Denver Broncos somehow
somehow would dramatically improve this
year the last thing Tom Brady and the
Patriots would want to do is have to go
back that's right yeah first of all you
don't want to go to Denver anyway but
then here's Joe Flacco a guy who's had
success against the Patriots who would
be the quarterback and then obviously if
it'll get to the point where the
Patriots have to go on the road to play
Denver that would mean the Broncos had a
really great season and that this Joe
Flacco experiment worked out incredibly
well we also have to mention another guy
who recently retired from the NFL though
who knows maybe he'll unretire and come
back and play football sooner rather
than later Mark Sanchez the last guy to
beat the Patriots Chris in the
divisional round they have not lost a
game in the round of eight since
January of 2011 when not all that long
after the Patriots destroyed the Jets on
a Monday night in December the Jets went
to Foxborough and splattered the New
England Patriots with Mark Sanchez and
that that stellar road playoff record
but got it done and that's why I make
this conversation that's why I hate it I
mean that Jets defense was phenomenal
that was the reason they won that
football game Mark Sanchez threw for a
197 yards in that game but we're gonna
give him the credit for winning that's
my biggest problem in the NFL right now
quarterback quarterback quarterback Oh
screw the other 10 Pro Bowlers on the
Jets team we're not gonna talk about
them we're gonna talk about Mark Sanchez
that's that's the issue I have with this
but you're right Rex Ryan was the only
AFC East guy that's given New England
true issues in the Belichick era he's
the only guy that stood up to them and
they were threatened by and I know when
I was working there in New England in
2012 into 2013 yeah that was considered
their rival it was certainly a level of
like intensity that went up in the
building when it was jet week there was
no denying that okay we've talked a lot
in recent weeks about our belief that
between the bills and the Jets one of
those two teams potentially rises up to
contend for a playoff berth all those
two teams
yeah and specifically of those two
quarterbacks Josh Allen in Buffalo Sam
garner with the Jets which one is more
likely to become a rival of Tom Brady
before Brady retired oh that is a good I
mean cuz you know I love both of these
guys and their I think their support
systems they're finally to where they
can flourish a little bit I want to give
Josh Allen the the edge here not because
I think he's a better player than Sam
Donald yet I think Sam darlings still
got an edge on Josh Allen maybe the
ceilings not as high but he still got
the edge as far as a player right now
but I'm taking in the Sean McDermott
factor you know Sean McDermott he he has
been a pain in the butt for that New
England offense he's got a great feel
for it even last year you know I know
know England beat them twice but if we
went back and watched those games you'd
realize who you know Buffalo really hung
in there with Derek Anderson a
quarterback and made life hard on Tom
Brady and things so if I had to take it
all too
they're that way but I do think Sam
Donald's a little notch above Josh Allen
right now is just being surgical having
a better feel for the game overall as a
quarterback Josh Allen still growing
into that a little bit
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports